nice car what's the retail on one of
those more than you can afford pal
Ferrari
smoke I think there are probably quite a
few Ferrari owners who felt called out
by this being able to afford one doesn't
necessarily make you capable of driving
one so with the release of Michael man's
new Ferrari film which takes a look at
the origin story of Ferrari seems like a
good time to look at some of the more
famous onscreen appearances of these
cars my name's Jake power back I'm a
collector car dealer and founding
partner of Morton Street Partners this
is the
[Music]
breakdown Ferris bu's day
off 1961 Ferrari 250 GT
California fortunately given what's
about to
happen this is a replica uh used in
Ferris bu they made three for the movie
One for show and a couple for
go they actually did a great job getting
a lot of these details right this was
the show replica I believe which was
based on a a dotson of all things there
was another replica used in some shots
uh which I owned briefly which was based
on a Plymouth with a slant 6 basically a
pickup truck they get a lot of details
right there were fewer than 100 they
were only about 50 the Cal spider is a
lot of people the Ferrari this is a
covered headlight version which is a
little bit more desirable my father
loves his car more life itself a man
with priorities so far out of whack
doesn't deserve such a fine automobile I
think this scene is so perfect and
Distilling down the life cycle of the
collector and you you sort of grow up if
you could sort of imagine you know one
day to skip school and do anything you
want the thing you would do is drive a
Ferrari fast to the streets and take it
off jumps and then by the time you're
old enough to maybe afford one all you
want to do is sort of fix it and look at
it and never drive it and it's such a
perfect sort of Confrontation of those
two things you know these are really
valuable objects even at the time this
movie was made they were really valuable
today it's quite a bit more valuable
we're talking 9 to 18 million a wide
range just cuz there's a lot of
different configurations and colors and
everything else I think actually the
sort of the main replica sold fairly
recently for a few hundred, which is um
good result for Dotson a lot of
companies do a great job of getting the
visuals somewhat right to somebody like
me a lot of things jump out quickly even
in this little tight frame the fender
flares the way that the sort of
headlights fit the buckets the hood
scoop is a little wonky it's a little
stubbier than it should be the wheels
are wrong the windshield's too thick
does it matter you know we're trying to
get something across here and and I
think they do it well they got the broad
Strokes of it I think to anyone looking
at this scene that looks like an
expensive Ferrari and sort of mission
accomplished Miami
[Music]
Vice so the Miami Vice Daytona spider is
one that is a little bit more obviously
a replica and I think it spent a lot of
time on screen there's a few details
here that are just totally off it's a
Corvette underneath a C3 Corvette and I
think that bummed Ferrari up pretty hard
it marks the beginning of them being
really protective of the way their cars
were used it's something they continue
today where if you own a Ferrari and
want to sort of mess with it sort of Do
Your Own Thing to it customize it
visually or in the engine It's Not
Unusual you get a ceas and assist they
treat the Silhouettes and the design of
their cars as their sort of real
patrimony and they don't want people
abusing it so fry saw the Daytona spider
replica and it doesn't do justice to
what a Ferrari is I think Ferrari
stepped in and said let's let's get you
the real issue they had this testarosa I
mean it was basically an on-screen
character it did a ton for the brand
today we all still think of it as sort
of the main character in Miami Vice is
the is the
[Music]
[Applause]
car how does that sound it it doesn't
sound quite right if we're being honest
here probably not the best thing in the
world to a cold rev a flat 12 uh box of
12 Ferrari engine out of the box but
that's a real car and this is an early
testos so what we call the monos speeco
or the single mirror or the flying
mirror you can see it has just one side
view mirror mounted quite high up on the
driver's side it also has the earlier
Wheels it's also white uh cocaine white
if we're talking Miami Vice I think a
lot of people look at the testos as a
car that's about appearances about Flash
this marked the beginning of a really
weird period of speculation on Ferrari
prices and the prices of new tester roas
even in the period skyrocketed to even
some people paying close to a million
dollars for these towards the end of the
80s in this weird sort of bubble that
happened they've come down now you can
get a tester Roa for
$150,000 these are tremendous cars to
drive really fast they handle well
they're a mid-engine 12 cylinder race
car with turn signals and most Ferraris
not just show um quite a bit at
go Magnum
[Music]
PI this is the way a Ferrari should be
driven like you're fleeing from attack
dogs I think if you're driving it uh any
less it's it's being wasted this car is
I think to me one of the more iconic
onscreen appearances it's also the bane
of every red Ferrari owner existence if
you own any red Ferrari from the 80s
people will go up to you and say Magnum
PI right this is sort of the low car on
the totem pole it was the first Ferrari
badged Mid Engine v8 car it was an
entry-level car this is full Fiat in
effect here lots of plastic on it lots
of sort of part spin stuff great cars to
drive truly but they were meant to be an
affordable and approachable entry point
well a lot of people think it's uh
flattering maybe say
Magnum PI right it's sort of today a
little bit of a knock Ferraris red is
the color Roso Corsa racing red it's
really tied into the identity of the
brand it actually goes back to a point
where racing was really a national sort
of Pride Point cars were actually
painted according to the nationality of
the manufacturer Italy was red Germany
was uh White and then silver England was
green so I British racing green if you
ask Ferrari why cars are red there's a
famous quote that you know if you hand a
child a box of crayons and tell him to
draw a racing car he'll use the red
cray golden
[Music]
eye who's that the next
go it's such a great scene hey I've
never tried it but I think you could do
eight sort of pirouettes in a 355 this
marks sort of the end of when you could
do stuff like that with a Ferrari in the
sense that you go much later into the
360s and 430s you have a lot of
electronic driving AIDS electronic
steering or brake control whatever else
these cars had power steering but by and
large you could sort of switch things
off and sort of have an analog
experience this is the TS version which
is sort of a semicon convertible you can
see the top comes off but you still have
those pillars behind you the sort of
flying buttress design and people tend
to fall into one camp or another they
either like the full spiders with the
full top that sort of folds in or these
ts's it was the first or second
generation of Ferraris where you can get
paddle shifters but most of them were
still manual transmission cars with an
old school shifter right there three
pedals which is the way a lot of people
feel a Ferrari should
be
Ferrari two objects cannot occupy the
same point in
Space the same moment in time the
Ferrari movie it takes on you know the
early days of Ferrari it was a racing
company which sold cars to subsidize
those racing efforts this was a point in
time where road racing was a deadly
Venture in the ' 50s a lot of road
racing was still long distances on
public roads you have Mele carrer pan
Americana Targo Florio these were races
where they shut the streets down they
gave the drivers a map and
said finish there melee was sort of The
Big Race the melee mia, miles this was
an Italian race there was Pride at stake
the movie culminates with the 57 melee
which was the final uh iteration of that
event the 315s was the car that was the
most advanced Ferrari at the time and
the one they ran the 315 was a
continuation of their mm program and the
mm stood for M Amilia these cars were
brutally fast and you know know could
could approach 200 mph one of the
reasons these cars are so beautiful is
they hadn't figured out how useful wings
were when it came to racing this is an
era we sometimes call sculpted by the
wind it was sort of fluid dynamics that
had originally inspired a lot of this
sort of let's think about the wind
realize that it's it's actually an IM
movable Force we need to slice through
typically cars of this period once they
got to these speeds up you know close to
200 mph they begin to lift and get very
dice
that was the limiting factor but Enzo
Ferrari famously felt that aerodynamics
were for people who couldn't build
engines he was about power you know they
began to relent and sort of incorporate
aerodynamics and covered headlights in
terms of making things more aerodynamic
but still uh it held true for them they
thought we needed to build the biggest
most powerful engine this was also a
period of time where there weren't
strict regulations on the size of the
engine Ford vers Ferrari
[Music]
so in this clip you have Christian Bale
in the GT40 and a 330 P3 being driven
next to him at Lal and one of the many
long Straits that they had there
probably in excess of 200 mph the 24
hours of Lal is today still really the
sort of defining endurance race it's 24
hours it used to start with the drivers
standing across from their cars a gun
would go off and you'd actually have to
run across the track get in your car and
start it and then drive off but the goal
was who can drive the farthest over 24
hours a lot of teams have said well
let's just go the fastest others said
let's have the biggest fuel tank you
know so we don't have to be in the pits
for as long the Ford Ferrari film got a
lot right about lont which is to say
it's an unusual track in that it's not
very difficult to drive it it's really
composed of a lot of long straight roads
you go really fast and you have to take
a turn and then you go really fast for a
long straight and turn again and you end
up in these sort of neck-and-neck
battles at extraordinarily high speeds
uh where it's about who blinks first and
who breaks last over 24 hours how many
moments are there like this where the
guys are white knuckling it pushing the
pedal all the way down probably not as
many as the film made it seem there's a
lot of Lal raising that's just sort of
maintaining your speed not using too
much
fuel oh my God oh my God you neck and
neck turning your head checking you know
Christian Bale sort of turning to the
left at 205 mph drivers tend to have
great peripheral vision and just a
general sense of where everyone is
without needing to
turn
[Music]
Lama
if you want to talk about Lon talk about
cars on film lont is sort of the movie a
little short on dialogue uh but a lot of
great driving shots and this is a movie
where a lot of the real cars were used
they even retrofitted a number of the
real cars with cameras and and they
actually drove during the race I mean
this was not a stage thing this was in
graded into the lar race in 1970 or
[Music]
71 this was a really interesting car and
that you begin to see the first stages
of heavy aerodynamics modeling that into
the automobile they made 25 of these it
was the beginning of hom liation rules
hom liation is a sort of sanctioning
body requires if you want to race you
have to have a real car that you built
25 of let's say so they couldn't just
build one insane prototype they had to
actually scale this thing in an effort
to sort of keep down some of the wacky
sort of over the toop engineering that
went into some of these cars this was a
successful but now wildly successful car
for Ferrari and it was their first entry
back into endurance racing after having
lost to Ford and kind of walking away
with their tail between their legs one
of the coolest parts of endurance racing
at least as it used to be run is to see
the length these teams would go to to
keep their cars running this is entirely
accurate to the way these sort of pit
Crews approach this you see them putting
on a new nose for one of the cars here
these are Zeus Fasteners which are sort
of quick release so you can take the
entire Bonnet off in a second and put a
new one on and quick release fuel
fillers you just saw there which were
featured on some of the Ferrari
competition road models where you can
sort of bang on it with one hand the cap
flies off and then slam it shut
again National Lampoon
Vacation
[Music]
I don't know what it was about The
Griswalds green station wagon that
compelled this to happen but you know
this kind of sets up the American view
of sort of the car hierarchy the station
wagon's kind of always been on the
bottom it still is today a little bit
it's sort of the you've given up and you
have the two- seat Italian sports car
with no roof on and it's like what am I
doing here where did it go
wrong this is another example of the the
TS configuration they never made a full
spider of the 308 some people would know
this as the target top that's what
Porsche used in their nomenclature and
there was a place to store your
convertible top behind the seats when it
was not needed and I think most people
drove it with the top off most of the
time looks a little bit awkward with
this sort of outdoor quality vinyl over
the top and especially in bright colored
cars it really breaks up the shape of
the car and this is the classic
configuration red tan Ferrari
the newest
[Music]
guy here we see Tom Cruz driving a 250
GTO pretty undisputably the ultimate
Ferrari to own they made 36 in total
these weren't particularly successful
cars in terms of racing most of them
almost almost all well all of them
really went to sort of private customers
but it's as beautiful as it gets when it
comes to car design those Half Moon
vents we see in the beginning are really
iconic part of this car they ended up
having to change those later but you can
see the sliding Windows the competition
fuel or on the outside these were cars
that were meant to go racing but are
ultimately actually very usable sort of
conventional cars another replica you
know they got a lot right but Wheels the
Shields the Chrome the a lot of details
are off on it not in a way that's again
affects things we get what they're
trying to say here if this was a real
car today it's you know approaching $100
million maybe over $100 million it is
sort of the dream to wake up one day and
have the streets and in Hatten to
yourself as well as all the street
parking you see on the upper west side
and those sort of opening shots I mean
that might that might be the most uh
sort of Fantastical part of
it Tower
Heist
what the hell
man give me that crowbar this is why we
say classic cars are a great investment
they're actually all gold underneath and
uh it's just a good place to put your
money the 250 l so this is one of the
first truly Comfort production cars the
Ferrari ever made lusso means luxury all
of the chrome trim around the windows
the bumpers the playful exhausts that
extend out and are polished these are
all things you didn't used to see on
Ferraris because they were detriments to
Performance but there was a growing
demand for these cars by the' 60s
already you know for I won so many races
everybody wanted the winning car but
people still wanted something
comfortable so this was plush when these
cars came out I mean they even inflation
adjusted they weren't terribly expensive
you didn't necessarily need to be uh a
billionaire to own one and there's lots
of great stories of sort of people who
just saved enough to buy their Ferrari
so the Luso is a car today that's really
popular with collectors they've been
refurbished maybe to a standard better
than they ever were new and those will
get over a million dollars Scent of a
[Music]
[Applause]
Woman alucino is driving probably one of
the worst Ferraris ever made but in one
of my favorite car scenes Ferrari scenes
uh in film they do a great job of
setting this car up because they walk
into a dealership on Park Avenue trying
to take out a tester Roa they are
roundly mocked and said hey but for a
couple Grand I'll let you drive the
mundal that's the same way the mundal is
sort of viewed today it's like you have
you own Bock I'll let you drive this
thing it's a little ungainly awkward
convertible top not very fast there were
a few versions that had sort of an
upgraded handling package which are very
cool um but these are really cheap cars
[Applause]
[Music]
today oh Charlie the scene itself is
great watching alpacino plays a blind
army colonel uh sort of be taught to
drive by his caretaker and it gets into
a point later where he has to try and
talk himself out of a ticket which is
always a hard thing to do in a Ferrari
you already look guilty but he manages
to get it done without the cop realizing
that he's blind and driving through the
streets of Brooklyn I think if you asked
the Ferrari World 99% of the people tell
you the mundal is the one not to own
it's a little too large a little too
heavy especially from this period of
time I would rather a 328 which you know
you're going to be paying three times as
much but I think you're getting three
times as much car
too The Fast and the
Furious more than you can afford pass
[Music]
Ferrari
smoke this scene really uh I think there
are probably quite a few Ferrari owners
who felt called out by this you buy a
Ferrari because you you know you've made
it You' got enough money to afford one
at some point you realize that being
able to afford one doesn't necessarily
make you capable of driving one or even
mean that it's going to be faster than a
lot of cars a fraction of the price it's
no secret you could save a lot of money
by buying a supr at the time with the
money you Sav by giant turbo whatever
else and you can out drag a Ferrari for
sure you know the truth though is today
these roles would actually be reversed
if you had the onscreen car this Supra
from Fast and Furious it's worth quite a
bit more than the
355 even if you've got a bone stock
sport roof Supra today with low miles
that's been unmodified it's potenti
potentially more valuable than the
355 The
[Music]
Rock why
not yeah the shifting stands out I mean
it's the classic you know car driving in
movies is if you want to go faster you
shift which is really not what you want
to be doing you shift when you have to
because you've run out of engine really
you want to hold it at a higher PM range
typically he's also really yanking on it
which doesn't help uh there's no need
you want to be quick but there's no need
to sort of really rip it in there this
is a car where you could still get a
gated manual transmission the gearbox
has slots for each of the gears to make
sure you're going into the right one it
also offers a really satisfying click
when you do you don't hear that in this
movie when he shifts which is sort of a
Miss I would think oh why not
this is the full spider here you can see
where the top folds completely into the
car there's no cillar that sort of stays
up Nicholas Cage famous car guy loves
his Ferraris but yeah he's really
selling that uh two three shift right
there Bad Boys
[Applause]
hold we see the guys driving a 550
Marinello full disclosure entirely bias
as I'm proud owner of a 1997 550
Marinello here's a case where Ferrari
provided real cars taking damage I
wouldn't be surprised if Ferrari
cooperated with them to sort of allow
this to happen but these are real 550
marinow being driven and the sounds like
a
550 these cars marked the beginning of
the montazuma era Ferrari who became the
chairman in the 9s and wanted to take
Ferrari back to a lot of its roots this
car is a front end engine naturally
aspirated 12 cylinder with three pedals
manual transmission it really did
ascribe to that sort of original Ferrari
recipe and you can see the uh the
shields on the side the yellow sketo
this is something you saw only on
ferrar's racing cars in the' 60s with
the cavalino rante the Prancing horse on
the side starting in this era brilliant
marketing move but you could optionally
get these shields as part of your car
it's a little bit more of an old man's
Ferrari I guess and that you you know
again front engined 12 cylinder and for
a lot of people if it doesn't have 12
cylinders it's not a Ferrari I'm not one
of those people but 12 cylinders doesn't
hurt Charlie's Angels Full
[Music]
Throttle here we've got uh Dei Moore uh
straight out of the ocean and into our
Enzo which you know at the time this was
only a $600,000 car so I guess you
didn't need to worry about drying off
first the Ferrari Enzo is one of the
first hypercars if you take off all the
exterior panels what you see underneath
is basically one of their Formula 1 cars
this is a very serious piece of kit
today they're worth around $3 million
let's call it some less some more only
400 were made one was gifted to the pope
they called it the Enzo and I think that
tells you how seriously they took this
car if they were going to put Enzo
Ferrari's name on it it's funny because
Enzo was always against a mid-engine car
for the street Fry Road cars were
traditionally always front engin so a
lot of ways I'm not sure this is what he
would have wanted to see but in terms of
putting forward a sort of technical
Masterpiece they managed to skin a
Formula 1 car in a body that would work
today this is fully cemented as a
collector car and it's part of the
lineage of super cars that Ferrari
produced starting with the 280 GTO it
was called then the F40
F50 the Enzo and now the La Ferrari
those are cars that are seen as the
Ferrari super cars of each
era